boxers alert you're looking live at the
hearing of president Trump's attorney
general nominee William Barr fielding
questions from lawmakers on Capitol Hill
and if anything major happens in the
hearing we will take you back in their
live bars spending most of the day
attempting to reassure Democrats that
they have no reason to be concerned
about the Moller investigation and a
previous memo he wrote about it I
believe it is vitally important that the
special counsel be allowed to complete
his investigation I believe it is in the
best interest of everyone the President
Congress and the American people that
this matter be resolved by allowing the
special counsel to complete his work
I wrote the memo as a former attorney
general who has often weighed in on
legal issues of public importance and I
distribute it broadly so that other
lawyers would have the benefit of my
views my memo was narrow explaining my
thinking on a specific obstruction of
justice theory under a single statute
that I thought based on media reports
the special counsel might be considering
but despite clearly laying out his
stance Democrats tried to hammer him on
the same issue
look like a job okay application that's
ludicrous if I wanted the job and was
going after the job there are many more
direct ways of me bringing myself to the
president's attention than writing an 18
page legal memorandum will you commit to
this committee that you will not allow
the president or his attorneys to edit
or change the special counsel report
before it is submitted to Congress or
the public eye I already said that I
would not permit editing of my report
and then as we've seen in previous
hearings Democrats also press the
nominee about whether he would be able
to stand up to President Trump what
would be your breaking point when would
you pick up and leave when is your Jim
mattis moment when the president has
asked you to do something that you think
is inconsistent with your oath I am NOT
going to do anything that I think is
wrong and I will not be bullied into
doing
anything I think is wrong by anybody
whether it be editorial boards or
Congress or the president I'm gonna do
what I think is right and then I want to
just play for you this other sound that
was caught off camera of Senator Dianne
Feinstein you want to listen and so you
see this a pretty easy road for him
heading to confirmation oh I think so
we'll see all right so I think that
she's reading the tea leaves that this
looks like a confirmation that might
just sail through interesting you think
I get all the interest in the
investigation but it's amazing how the
how the media and and the Democrats are
following the same script super obsessed
with how this will impact Muller
I mean if an asteroid came and wiped out
half of the United States the the most
important the lead at MSNBC and CNN will
be how does this impact a molar probe
well they're 150 million people dead but
we need to know more about the molar
probe and then justice it's like every
question is how are you gonna deal with
Donald Trump so the it's basically boils
down to this we hate Trump you like
Trump we hate you too so he's not
applying for AG he's applying to gain
entrance into the Donald Trump hate club
and he's got it like he's got to say all
the right things I believe there's a
tree house out back for that there might
be the secret knock you have here Jessie
a nominee who's he's already been the
Attorney General before and in fact when
the Senators were not referring to him
as mr. Barr they would have to say
general because that it was the title
and you hold it for the rest of your
life and he's a guy who was willing to
come back he was almost going to into
semi-retirement he's willing to be a
public servant how do you think it went
today I think it went really well and
one would agree with me so he doesn't
speak I believe he handled all these
senators very deftly and this was not a
Jeff session situation where he's like
oh he was very smooth and he was very
direct and everything he said was based
on law when he was asked oh you know
what would you base a recruit of recusal
on he said the facts and it stopped a
few senators in their tracks they want
him and I
with Greg they they don't want a Trumper
as a G they want a week a G they want
someone that's gonna recuse at the
slightest whiff of controversy and they
want someone that's gonna treat Muller
like a God and I think he kind of you
know straddled that pretty well he said
if there's something that's gonna happen
I will deal with it but I'm not going to
abdicate my responsibility as a G I have
an authority here and I'm gonna be a
strong Attorney General but he also had
said in this memo that Comey deserved to
be fired and Muller going after an
obstruction case against the president
was kind of on weak legal ground and
Muller shouldn't have stacked his team
with Democrats it didn't look good and
he said and I think that's caught
president Trump's attention is that
there's a lot of reasons to go after
Hillary on uranium one and things like
that more than to go after Trump rush a
collision in twenty six not uranium one
again there - speaking of President
Trump meeting with Bill Barr he was
asked about that let's play that sound
and we'll get one to react the president
wanted to know we said oh you know Bob
Muller how well do you know Bob Muller I
told him how well I knew Bob Muller and
I said bob is a is a straight shooter
and should be dealt with as such and
sort of he said something to the effect
like so are you envisioning some role
here and I said you know actually mr.
president right now is like I couldn't
do it you know I just my personal and my
professional obligations are such that
I'm unable to do it and one in another
exchange mr. Barr said that he does not
believe Bob Muller would ever be
involved in a witch-hunt so do you think
Democrats will be satisfied with this
hearing today no you know to me this is
about Trump wants to control the Justice
Department I think that's why he forced
out Jeff Sessions who was a Trump
loyalist but had recused himself so I
think the standards Dana for the
Democrats was if the ethics officials
come to you and say mr. Attorney General
we think you should recuse yourself will
you abide by their findings and he said
no he said he would go with his own
sense of whether or not he should be
recused similarly and I think this is
the big point it's not
matter of you know hate anybody club
there was a question about whether or
not he will release the report the
Muller report and he said you know what
I the way that we deal with I think what
they're called declination memos where
they decline to and to prosecute
somebody's we don't go out and talk
about them right and so we may not
release all of it well guess what the
polls are pretty clear on this it's like
a majority of Americans say his
number-one job should be release
whatever Muller finds don't cover it up
don't let Giuliani edited it put it out
there for the American people and he
refuses to say there and there have been
Republican senators Katie who have said
that they also want that report to be
public but it will be the Attorney
General's decision well it's been such a
big topic of conversation for the
country for the last two years that it
should be released in full as much as
possible but he didn't say he wasn't
releasing it for reasons of personal
political purposes or because the
president doesn't necessarily want it
released he specifically referred back
to the rules and regulations that are in
the Justice Department when it comes to
releasing reports like this but one
thing that I caught today that I found
interesting is I think there was a bit
of a missed opportunity because
everything was so focused on Russia that
all these other issues kind of got
ignored for example there were questions
today about Bill Bars role as Attorney
General in the 1990s when there was a
lot of crime there's a reason why
violent crime and murder in America
today has been cut in half it's a result
of a lot of the policies that they put
into place and as you have Cory Booker
and Kamala Harris and president Trump
pushing forward with criminal justice
reform which is important he really did
a good job of saying look I'm not gonna
apologize for the things that we did in
the 1990s to bring down the crime across
cities in America at the same time I am
open to the idea that maybe we can pull
some pull back on some of those policies
now that we have solved a lot of the
problem in places like New York and
Washington DC Chicago came up as one
place where it hasn't been solved so
that's an issue that will be ongoing for
the next 10 20 years and I don't think
that they really he also said Gregg that
he would not target marijuana none like
the laws and they mess with what the
states are trying to do that's a good
thing yeah I guess that's a good thing
big well I think it's it's
that was the other problem with sessions
was I think that he wasn't gonna go for
it I think that would that's the
direction of the country and I do agree
that we have to be really careful about
talking about how great this police
reform thing is gonna be because the
facts are the facts we saw a dramatic
reduction in crime and that had
something to do with policies that were
now kind of saying hey maybe we don't
need them anymore and that's the loop
that's the thing that always happens
after something works we all start
thinking maybe we don't need it anymore
like walls
we don't need walls anymore windows
theory but yeah and he was very strong
on border security he said he supported
barriers where they were necessary and
he was also very against sanctuary
cities so I thought everybody watching
should be pretty pleased with this guy
you know one thing I would say on is I'm
a Democrats perspective he's not Matt
Whittaker strategy along I think so